you might not be scared of zombies on TV
but you should definitely be scared of
these fungi in real life
for those expecting to see a one-to-one
recreation of naughty dog and Sony's
2013 PlayStation 3 game The Last of Us
in the 2023 adaptation by HBO the
opening likely came as quite the
surprise instead of opening with Sarah
giving Joel his birthday present we
instead jump back to 1968 where we see
an epidemiologist named Dr Newman warned
the world of a fungus called cordyceps
which can take over the minds of ants
and bend them to their will fungus
starts to direct the ant's Behavior
telling it where to go what to do like a
puppeteer with a marionette in the world
of The Last of Us which although
grounded for a zombie show and game is
still full of impossible creatures and
Abominations one might be forgiven for
assuming that the cordyceps fungus is a
fictional creation however we regret to
inform you that the cordyceps fungus is
real and it's just as scary as it sounds
much like the scientists discussed in
the premiere there are types of fungi
that feed on the living one such fungus
is ophio cordyceps unilateralists which
National Geographic reported on in 2019
the fungus floods ants brains with
chemicals takes over their muscles and
controls them to move to the perfect
height and temperature for the fungus to
grow then spreads its spores to control
even more ants there are a couple of
differences between how this fungus
works and how it works in humans in The
Last of Us however for starters although
it affects the ant's brains it doesn't
actually invade them as scientists found
no fungal cells within the ants brains
that means that the fungal outgrowths
found in infected such as clickers in
the show and games wouldn't be possible
with this fungus even if it were somehow
able to infect humans however there is
another fungus that does create a
scarily similar outgrowth from the head
according to National Geographic the
fungus ophio cordyceps synensis can form
a growth from the heads of moth
caterpillars while you couldn't pay us
enough to go anywhere near those things
the infected caterpillars are actually
used in traditional Tibetan and Chinese
medicine to cure all sorts of diseases
not all types of cordyceps are are
malignant toward their hosts as species
that take root in Japanese cicadas may
help them process nutrients from sap
imagine an alternate universe to The
Last of Us where instead of causing an
infected horde the cordyceps fungus
becomes a popular snack to boost humans
digestion but these aren't the only
fungi that can take over their hosts
Minds according to National Geographic
the entomophthra mosque translated from
Greek as insect destroyer of the fly is
able to take over fly's actions and
cause them to fly to the perfect height
for sport dispersal which it does before
then striking a death pose the perfect
angle for the fungus to grow from its
corpse and spread more spores there is
also the masospora cicadina which drugs
at cicada hosts so much that it causes
its abdomen to partially fall off the
rest is similar to what other fungi do
to their hosts move it to an ideal
climate for spreading spores kill it
then take over its body and do it all
over again the one thing consistent in
all of these cases however is that
infection occurs exclusively through air
born sport dispersal an element that was
present in the games but was removed
from the HBO show although The Last of
Us certainly did its homework the part
about infecting its hosts by biting them
appears to be purely the work of zombie
fiction The Last of Us airs on HBO and
HBO Max Sundays at 9pm ET
[Music]